because it was Churchill he still held
in such high esteem in such affection I
mean that we could the watchmaker we had
you know a copy of his watch
completely made which was worth 70,000
pounds and so or things like that to get
him the authenticity of the Churchill
sort of memorabilia but the hardest
thing to find was something called a
clop and he'd never went anywhere
without the clock now a clock we know as
a hole-punch but he always wanted a
hole-punch he uses those little sort of
Treasury tags he hated staples so it was
all those idiots and critique moments as
the size and the silent typewriters so
it's all of those things that you
wouldn't know about until you sort of
started to research Churchill and his
and the whole thing you know and it was
the cigars were the same and the Pol
Roger champagne and Jacqueline went to
as I'm sure she'll tell you she went to
the original tailors and got his
original fabrics and measurements and
all that planning so it's a very
interesting kind of backing into
something so real and you know the
Churchill at the heart of the film was
incredibly real in the way he was
represented and Gary's performance and
everything and then as we go out we are
doing a feeling of what was that period
and what was happening and you know so
it wasn't necessarily a kind of complete
verbatim copy but he was absolutely key
there were so many scenes because there
was there was chart well there was
Buckingham Palace
there was the House of Commons which was
interesting it was bombed in yes I think
it was I mean there's all sorts of talk
there was that there was a set that kind
of lived until about a year prior to us
filming and then there was talk of
possibly shooting in the real House of
Commons but then we found out you can
shoot in there but you can't sit in
there which is kind of this weird law
that you can't sit on the seats so so we
decided to build it and what was
interesting is that the House Commons
that we know today was in fact built in
the 1950s and it was a sauna based on a
simplified version of what was there
because in fact it got bombed in 1941 so
the House of Commons we recreated as a
set is based on the original House of
Commons and and that was great because
you know we could totally we could make
it much grimy and dirty and darker
and much more lived-in which kind of
suited the whole atmosphere of the film
that we were the atmosphere of the look
of the film we were making those shots
we're very used to seeing it in a
contemporary fashion where they used to
seeing it kind of shot in certain ways
and because we were on the stage at
least and it meant that you know we
could Joe could have all his bells and
whistles and toys and cranes and you
could go outside the set and get those
amazing top shots and things and Bruno
could light it beautifully as well
[Music]